[Musique]
demain c'est ton anniversaire et quand
tu auras fini j'aimerais que tu fasses
quelque chose tu veux vraiment que
j'aille chercher mon cadeau amène à
canet quel point je suis content de moi
ta mère m'a commandé quelque chose il
faut que nous suivent immédiatement et
[Musique]
notre monde court actuellement un grand
danger et il n'y a que la déesse du vent
vers qui est en mesure de le sauver
[Musique]
saleh
moi j
on se croirait dans un coin fait c'est
magnifique le problème c'est que l'écolo
disparu
couleurs way
il m'a dit
ok si le cycle de l'eau s'interrompt
alors toutes les couleurs disparaissent
québec et encore
[Musique]
oublions de regarder autour de nous nous
sommes deux
sensible à la beauté toute simple
achetons monde
en soi il en vaut la peine
[Musique]